hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back out for Annika and
today we're gonna be talking some about
of the ruling faction characters that
being Chianti and Shaolin should be
showing off some of their armor and what
it looks like as well some of the
gameplay demos and how their move sets
work is always like to be if you do
enjoy subscribe if you're new I cover
the informational side of foreign or
that being balance changes patch notes
news hero info and leaks and with that
let's get started so first up we're
gonna be talking about the armor and
we're gonna be first would be looking at
chi on d now this is some of the images
of chianti in game the first one is the
default look of him at street level one
the first thing you're gonna be getting
once you start playing him what the next
image is I'm gonna be showing being some
of the higher rank to gear many looks
include plume and different hairstyles
as well as armor patterns which look
absolutely amazing and most of these
characters have back stories from their
armor especially the Shaolin with his
tattoos throughout his body which is a
really cool miniature detail to look at
next up is the Shaolin and the first
image you're gonna be seeing is what
Shaolin is at level one default with
like last time the next images being
some high-level gear variation like
armband changes facial features and
tattoos as well they didn't show
anything for the other two characters
that mean nuke Xia and Jang Joon so that
we're probably getting more info on
these characters during the summer as to
not spoil anything in the new update and
as well this isn't the only armor for
the characters this is still a work in
progress and we have tons of months
before this even releases so there's
probably gonna be tons more armor
ornaments weapons and all that good
stuff being showed later throughout the
months next up we have the Chi on D
gameplay demo and we're gonna move into
Shaolin and a little bit later in the
video but firstly we're gonna be looking
at Chianti and he has simple to chain
attacks that just being two variations
of a button being light heavy heavy
heavy heavy light all that good stuff
as shown on screen he also has a side
dodge heavy which is a crazy slow and a
powerful attack which you can cancel
into a side dodge heavy into a into
another one from a different direction
or the same direction as shown on screen
as well these can also lead into chain
attacks if you cancel them
the next two are palm strike and dragon
kick and palm strike is the punch that
he does with his pump as the name says
is another move which can be followed up
into a live attack or from a light
attack in general and the kick move as
you saw is the dragon kick and this is
accessible from after heavy attacks or
the first hit of the zone attack which
you can cancel and yes you can ledge
with the dragon kick because of how far
you kick the
guys you don't need to hit the opponent
with the light or heavy you can simply
just strike their sword and you can do
the palm strike and dragon kick just
fine Chandi really doesn't have a huge
move list in his arsenal but they're
very hard-hitting and here's a little
cool execution they showed for chianti
during the stream next up is Shaolin and
the first move you're gonna be seeing is
the death point strike which is three
lights from either the left guards dance
or the right guards dance all lights are
confirmed after the first hit but you
have to time them similar to PK's bleed
attack to land all the hit so it's gonna
take a little bit of timing ticket the
timing down for that and any hit can go
into the Chieftains very similar to
Highlander second offensive stance in
this mode you can kick which can go into
a sweep he also has a top-heavy
unblockable and also has counter attack
lights very similar to a crushing
counter strike which also does some
heavy damage and Shaolin also has a
deflect this wall which is a really
quick whip with his staff so nothing too
crazy like bleed or any of that stuff
but still some decent damage on the
deflect as well in in Chi stands he also
has some undoubtable side heavies and
also a very long attack which can be
fainted about half way through and then
lastly to end this section I'm going to
be showing you the two executions they
showed during the stream for the
gameplay and that guy is gonna be the
end of the video hopefully you guys did
enjoy that like I said if you if you're
big fan of nuke CEO or Zhong Xue we're
gonna be seeing lots of that and the
summer and probably a lot more with
these current characters Shaolin and
Xian be probably in the next couple
weeks as well so with that like the V if
you do enjoy subscribe if you're new I
covered the informational side of for
honor that always being the balance
changes patch notes news and hero info
and leaks and stuff like that
my two most recent videos will be on
screen if you guys want to check that
out when that guys okay have a great
yesterday they for watching the video
peace out